m moussa tchangari et journaliste
secrétaire général de l'association
alternative espace citoyens
bonsoir à vous merci d'être en direct ce
soir sur rtl france
alors comment s'est déroulée cette
journée de vote bon on peut dire
globalement le voit que s'est déroulée
dans des conditions acceptables
comparé aux critères précédents les
élections locales et régionales
je pense que les bureaux ouverts a
surtout et on voit qu'il ya un certain
william a en tout cas c'est ce qu'on
peut lire à travers des postes sur les
réseaux sociaux etc et moi même en train
année là où existait quelques bureaux de
vote
j'ai pu constater que presque du passé
de la global mag bien et il n'a pas
beaucoup d'incidents qui sont signalés
et donc du point de vue du doublement on
peut dire c'est plus ou moins j'imagine
qu'on a voté en tout cas assez
massivement à niamey et dans les autres
parties du pays à votre avis
oui à toi le gouverneur et elle sait
c'est que vraiment tous les reportages
extra tout ce que j'ai suivi des gens
disent qu'un longuement à vous dire que
les gens sont conscients de l'importance
de ce critère là et il saura se
mobiliser maintenant on verra ce que ça
va donner mais en tout cas pour le
moment ça va ya elle s'appelle malgré
moi qui montre que c'est en aura
probablement un taux de participation
assez énervé est-ce que la sécurisation
de ce double scrutin était à la hauteur
de l'enjeu
en tout cas est bon vous savez à des
zones du pays qui sont en insécurité sur
notamment le cas du la région de
tillabéri ce n'est qu'à dans la région
de diffa ou ce matin encore on signalé
des tirs nourris à la lute on ne sait
pas si diarra camara fois met en quête
d'une place et peut-être des groupes
armés qui se font rappeler mais et du
point de vue de leur utilisation dans
les bureaux on ça va mais vous savez
dans beaucoup d'endroits ils sécurité
voire probablement prise est un peu sur
la participation et la sécurité du pays
c'était l'un des enjeux de ce scrutin
sur le plan politique pas de troisième
mandat finalement donc pour mahmadou
issoufou et c'est une avancée saluée au
delà des frontières du niger le
président sortant qui parle on l'a
entendu d'alternance démocratique c'est
vrai il a tenu ses promesses quand même
wii board je ne sais pas si on peut
parler d'avancée en tant que tel parce
que bon c'est inscrit dans la
constitution il n'est pas prévu que le
président soit candidat et ne l'est pas
et c'est tant mieux
contre un mois peut-être à certains pays
mais ce n'est pas un soin il avancé
l'avancé ce serait vraiment que après
tout le monde reconnaisse que le scrutin
a été libre transparent et c'est rare
c'est de ce point de vue il ya problème
il ya problème parce que vous savez le
processus qui est en cours n'a pas faire
l'objet d'un consensus au sein de la
classe politique
il ya donc une bonne partie de la classe
prise notamment les partis de
l'opposition et qui ont décrié le sida
sa globalité qui ont délaissé le fichier
électoral et la façon dont la ville a
été fait qui devront montrer qu'ils
n'ont pas confiance à la commission
nationale électorale indépendante qui
ont montré qu'elles n'ont pas confiance
à la cour constitutionnelle qui est
l'arbitré budget électoral et vous savez
également que c'est un parti conteste la
légitimité du candidat du parti au
pouvoir ça ce que il considère qu'il ne
remplit pas se lancer partie l'année et
les conditions pour être candidat à
savoir les conditions liées à la
nationalité et plusieurs recours sur
l'éligibilité du candidat et là on peut
s'attendre à ce que les résultats des
six critères fassent l'objet de
contestations pas sera fait on veut dire
que le sculpteur et ré élection qui
parle d'un objet de votre sage abord
bien entendu on ne prenait pas le
résultat si d'aventuré le candidat du
parti au pouvoir le gagne et bien être à
partir de mois ou alice timide et a été
artiste et dont on peut faire
l'hypothèse que les autres continueront
à contester sur cette base là altor
contesté mohamed bazoum à celui
c'est lui le candidat du parti au
pouvoir considéré comme le dauphin de
mamadou issoufou il est contesté à cause
de sa nationalité pas parce qu'il est il
est désigné un peu comme le le
successeur naturel de mahamadou issoufou
we all à l'argument de la cotisation à
10 ans qui parce que avec ses papiers ne
sont pas tout à fait inverse et qui va
et n'est pas pour eux donc un candidat
disons et qui remplit la condition
d'être rémunéré est d'origine
voilà c'est ça le dise ça qui fait le
plus débat c'est une des maisons la
contestation et plusieurs du coup et
voir la cour et la cour
constitutionnelle a rejeté pratiquement
toutes les deux coups et tous les coups
de 12 ans qui ont été faits à ce nouveau
port tant que ça je pense que ça va être
le sujet de la participation si il se
posera plus mais s'il gagne c'est clair
que moi je m'attends à ce que d autres
continuent à tester cette dernière
question vous sachant gary globalement
le niger est compris lorsqu'il ya eu des
coups d'état la paix a toujours été
préservés dans votre pays comment vous
expliquer cette exception africaine
bon je ne sais pas je ne sais pas si
c'est vraiment une exception
vous savez ya plusieurs pays africains
qui ont réalisé des élections et des
élections d'air au moins contesté même
parfois que celle-là du niger megan a
réapparu viennent de faire une élection
bon c'est vrai c'est pas un pays du pré
carré jeune espoir français mais y'a pas
quelques jours d'exception et attendons
vraiment la suite du processus pour voir
si vraiment on est dans un cas de figure
où on peut vraiment célébrer quelque
chose mais je sais que cette élection là
et a suscité beaucoup d de cotisation
déjà avoir lui aussi ce n'était pas
facile
les autres partis disons malgré vu
l'espoir les parties de nos pulsions et
nomme certains candidats qui étaient
dans la dans les parties faisait partie
de la majorité
je pense qu'une participation à ces
élections là malgré veut est d'accord
les résultats peuvent faire l'objet de
contestations et on peut aussi avoir une
situation post électorale qui pourrait
être difficile peut-être à gérer et au
cas où
comme je le dis dans l'hypothèse où
c'est le candidat du parti au pouvoir
tirer il je m'attends à ce que niait des
problèmes c'est possible merci beaucoup
à vous à vos sacs shanghai et je
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste kata
générale de l'association alternative et
ses citoyens